the lockdown of Wuhan City origin of the
coronavirus and the surrounding Hubei
province is now in its second week so
how are the more than 50 million people
they're coping we spoke with a few
through video chat to get an idea
Wang Zhao Zhang and his wife live in
Wuhan their two sons postponed their
trip from Hong Kong for the Lunar New
Year because of the virus the dates keep
getting pushed back and their biggest
concern is the uncertainty the obvious
stress of concern about being infected
with the corona virus but what is it
like just the other stress about
supplies about your daily life I think
the Walia found to the problems I'm just
worried about suspecting how long I
would have to stay at suit hope this is
let me nervous a little bit because the
things change he says he gets his
information from friends outside China
and contacts at the local hospital Jing
Minh City is next to Wuhan like its
neighbor it is sealed off and its
streets empty this video was shot by
Wong Shen he has a supply of mass and
food in the fridge
his parents are with him but his wife
and young daughter are with her parents
outside Hebei province I feel more
relaxed because who Bay province is now
seriously hit by the epidemic the place
where they are at now has far fewer
cases so I feel a bit relief that
they're not with me they're safer at the
moment our biggest concern is when will
we have medication for the virus this is
what we care about most well those
people in whom a province are under a
forest lockdown there are some
communities across China who are self
imposing a lockdown like this one on the
outskirts of Beijing they're not letting
anyone into this community from the
outside they're worried someone might
carry the virus inside no matter the
type of lockdown government enforced or
self imposed with the spread of the
virus accelerating no one knows how long
these communities and remain safe
Scott hilar al-jazeera Beijing